herzlich willkommen ja die korona
pandemie hat unser leben und unser
denken ganz schön durcheinander
gewirbelt und in solchen krisenzeiten es
ist besonders wichtig einen klaren kopf
zu bewahren
darum machen wir heute einen crashkurs
in logischen denken das ist jetzt finden
oh mein gott logik keine angst sitzt
jemand gegenüber der das alles ganz
einfach und verständlich erklären kann
christoph fisser arbeitet als philosoph
an der universität zürich und gab da
über viele jahre logik kurse für
studierende herzlich willkommen herr
pfister hilft ihnen denn die logik in
der gegenwärtigen krise nein ich denke
nicht dass die logik mir persönlich
jetzt hilft in dieser krise es gibt auch
nicht irgendwie soweit rasieren corona
fehlschluss spezifisches was mir schon
auffällt ist dass es sozusagen neue
begründung zusammenhänge gibt dass sich
leute überlegen sind die maßnahmen zum
beispiel die einschränkung des
öffentlichen lebens gerechtfertigt
verhalte ich mich richtig verhalten sich
die anderen richtig und so weiter und
dann sind natürlich immer begründung
versuche und wo begründet wird da wird
dokumentiert und wo argumentiert wird da
passieren auch fehler ja man sich in
solchen krisenzeiten anfälliger für für
denkfehler
das könnte sein dann das wäre
wahrscheinlich in eine psychologische
frage es kann natürlich schon sein dass
gerade wenn man von ängsten geprägt ist
oder so dass man weniger klar ist ihm
denken oder sich hier dazu verleiten
lässt ihn wäre das zu glauben was man
sonst irgendwie hätte man genügend zeit
und muse und eben keine angst sondern
dann nicht so für wahr halten würde
beispielsweise sie sind punkt wird
philosoph schreiben derzeit an ihrer
habilitation waren dafür auch längere
zeit jetzt in den usa in kalifornien und
in new york sind es wieder zurück an der
uni zürich und da gaben sie knapp zehn
jahren habe ich logik größe ja insgesamt
habe ich da so eine übung geleitet
mit vielen studierenden das ist ein
bisschen speziell weil es auch eine das
ist sozusagen das oder war lange das
einzige pflichtfach also viele
studierende sind dann auch immer ganz
abgeschreckt weil das sind wir außerdem
hat sich konsolen da war ich nie gut
drin aber ich denke das ist der lauf
taucht überraschend ist wie oder
entwickeln auch da im laufe dieses es
noch zwei semestrigen große sorgen
ganzes jahr
freude ja eigentlich auch weil es ist
natürlich nicht nur wie mathematik
sondern es hat auch sehr viel mit
sprachanalyse zu tun und und deswegen
bin ich auch ist es zurecht sodass die
logik irgendwo auch immer ein teil einer
philosophie ausbildung ist ja und in der
erfolgen stunde möchten wir so ein
bisschen das wichtigste mitnehmen was
logische schlüsse sind was gute
argumente sind und wo die denkt fallen
lauern im alltag vielleicht möchten sie
am anfang ganz kurz sagen was eigentlich
logik ist ganz einfach gesagt das ist
eine sehr sehr große frage ich würde mal
vielleicht anfang mit dem mit dem wort
logisch dass es natürlich irgendwo auch
fest verankert ist in unserem
sprachgebrauch mich logisch kann man
meinen seite 27 oder nachvollziehbar
leuchte dahin also oft wird es so
gebraucht ein sagt ja logisch oder
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das was
die logik in einem engeren sinne
charakterisieren würde da wird logik er
so in einem weiteren sinne definiert aus
die lehre des tests folgerichtigen
denkens und argumentieren und dann
vielleicht noch ein bisschen enger die
formale logik die lehre des korrekten
schließen damit möglich aber auch so
verwendet zu einem jahr vielleicht ein
bisschen dramatischen signal wenn man
etwas sagen dann auf die system acet von
etwas ansprechen will sowie die die
logik des scheins oder die logik des
schmerzes oder sowas
und ich denke so wie wir heute darüber
unser gespräch wird voran wahrscheinlich
in dieser zweiten bedeutung inwiefern
logik des denkens und argumentieren
kenia und dass sie haben schon gesagt
dass das logische schlüsse die lehre des
des gültigen rekord anschließen also aus
einigen sätzen andere sätze logisch
ableiten und da haben wir ein beispiel
mal vorbereitet einen sogenannten so
logisch muss wo man als allgemeinen
setzen dann irgendwie in spezifischen
satz ableitet und hier sehen wir das
beispiel vielleicht können sie das kurz
erläutern was mich hier sehr gerne
also wir haben ja natürlich auch schon
so aber hatte die prämisse und
konklusion dass sie sozusagen auch das
was ein argument ausmacht und das ist
ein zentraler begriff natürlich für die
logik das argument und ein argument
gesteht einfach aus prem ist und gucken
wie sie wissen sind so voraussetzungen
oder leichte haben annahmen genau das
sind dinge aus und setzte von deren
wahrheit man ausgibt und die konklusion
ist an die folgerung der unterkommission
ist aus was aus diesen prämissen folgt
oder zumindest es wird behauptet die
folge die konklusion in diesem fall ist
es tatsächlich so dass die konklusion
aus dem prämientopf alle menschen sind
sterblich alle philosophen sind menschen
sind beides besetzung daraus folgt dass
alle philosophen sterblich sind leider
ist aber etwas folgt und dieses dieser
schluss ist jetzt logisch gültig weil
wenn die ersten beiden prämissen war
sind dann muss auch die die konklusion
die folge aber jetzt endlich
vorweggenommen die der gültigkeit der
ist auch extrem zentral natürlich führt
für die logik es ist genau wie sie sagen
der schluss ist gültig oder die
kompression folgt aus den prämissen
heisst nichts anderes aus dass es
unmöglich ist dass die prämissen bau
sind die kommission aber falsch
was nicht heißt ist dass die prämissen
tatsächlich wahr sind also ein schluss
kann auch gültig sein wenn die prämissen
eben nicht war sie ja wir haben noch
dazu ein beispiel unter verdeutlichen
man könnte sagen alle tiere sind
kurzsichtig erste prämisse alle katzen
sind ihre zweite prämisse und dann folgt
daraus alle katzen sind kurzsichtig
genau das heißt jetzt also die erste
prämisse ist ist falsch oder es gibt der
tiere die sehr gut sehen in die weite
aber trotzdem obwohl der falsche sätze
drin sind ja ist dieser schloss dieses
dieser schutz ist gültig das argument
ist gültig es ist nicht möglich dass
diese prämissen bahn sind die kommission
also falsch das ist die bedingung dafür
dass ein ein argument gültig ist also
logisch oder formal gültig das ist
natürlich auch hier für katzen elefanten
einsetzt und dann haben sie gleich
wieder so etwas wie alle elefanten sind
grundsätzlich als eine kommission die
bar ist
sie können damit herumspielen wie sie
wollen wenn sie die gleichen begriffe
ersetzen durch andere also ich kann zum
beispiel auch alle tiere sind
berufstätig alle katzen zensiere also
sind alle katzen berufstätig ist
völliger quatsch habe ist ein gültiges
argumente aber es ist wichtig jetzt zum
mitnehmen glaube ich dass sich die logik
eigentlich nicht um die wahrheit schert
sondern um die wache der einzelnen sätze
sondern nur um die gültigkeit um die
schlussfolgerung dass da uns genau ganz
genau es geht dass er ganz oft in der
logik um diese hypothetische denken dass
ich denke das ist ein zentraler
charakteristischer zug der logik dass
man eben gar nicht das ganze sehr darauf
ankommt was jetzt wahr ist sondern
vielmehr darauf ankommt was war wäre
wenn etwas war werde es ist ja komisch
weil diese art von sülo kissmann diese
schlussfolgerung begegnen uns im alltag
ja eigentlich nie wenn wir etwas
begründen also wenn ich irgendwie sage
ich
trinkwasser weil ich durstig bin oder
hier drin ist kein wodka weil ich mich
sonst nicht mehr konzentrieren könnte
oder sowas dann sieht das begründung
aber es sind ja keine logische schlüsse
wie wir das jetzt gesehen haben heißt
das denn dass wir im alltag meistens
dass die begründung irgendwie logisch
faust sind oder nicht nicht günstig sind
das würde ich so nicht sagen oft sind
begründung und verkürzt
das heißt die sind vielleicht jetzt
nicht so wie sie sagen detektiv oder
ganze reduktionen dahinter sondern es
reicht auch einfach auf zu sagen das ist
so weil etwas anderes punkt aus schloss
aber oft sind stecken dahinter natürlich
prinzipien die man stillschweigend
annimmt oder auch weiter prämissen die
man die man die man annimmt und so
könnte man dann die begründung sehr wohl
zu einem gültigen argument im besten
fall rekonstruieren wir reden dann von
einer konstruktion also man stellt das
ganze dann als als argument dass dann
auch in sich detektiv eben gültig ist
das heißt okay wir verschweigen
bestimmte sachen bestimmte anlagen
sprechen die gar nicht aus aber man
könnte viele dieser begründung sozusagen
aufdröseln und daraus logische schlüsse
machen dass es vielleicht richtig zu
sagen das nur weil man sich verschweigt
oder so ist eine begründung nicht
unbedingt schlecht die kann sehr wohl
sehr gut sein und das wirklich sein
nur die aufgabe so von von logisch
geschulten leuten sage ich es dann oft
als ich den komplexeren begründung
kontexten halt auch diese versteckten
prämissen zu finden
und sollte sich zum beispiel eine
prämisse finden die nicht so
unproblematisch ist
sie habe wesentlich dazu gehört um das
argument als gilt als darstellen zu
können
dann hat man natürlich auch eine gewisse
schwäche des argument schon gefunden
also das ist sozusagen die die arbeit
des biologisch geschulten dass es wenig
zu machen
jetzt haben wir beispiele gesehen für
sogenannte detektion wo man sozusagen
von einem allgemein satz auf etwas sehr
besonderes ableitet und es gibt ja noch
so genannte induktion
das kann man mit diesem tag ihr habe ich
kurz erläutern
also wenn ich zum beispiel jetzt weiß
dass alle tischtennisbälle in diesen in
dieser tüte weiß sind dann weiß ich auch
jedes dass ich rausnehmen wird weiß man
das wäre eine reduktion oder genau und
was wäre jetzt eine induktion wir bei
einem induktiven schluss sollte es auch
eine eine eine reform von argumente wir
schließen sehr häufig induktiv ist eben
gerade nicht so dass es nicht sein kann
dass die prämissen war die konklusion
aber falsch ist das heißt wenn sie jetzt
zum beispiel um bei diesem so bleiben
wenn es jetzt schon vier fälle
rausgenommen haben da ja dann haben sie
vielleicht schon gründe zu denken dass
alle bälle in diesem sind nur wenn sie
jetzt sozusagen jedes natürlich seien es
eben auch ein schwarzer vw nichts das
heißt es es ist eben doch möglich dass
die prämissen war die konklusion aber
falsch ist also um es ein bisschen zu
veranschaulichen das würde ich sagen ist
ein charakterzug von induktiven
argumenten die müssen deswegen nicht
schlecht sein aber es ist eben ganz
spezifisch dadurch charakterisiert dass
die prämissen war sein können und die
kunden noch und es könnte letztlich eben
ein schwarzer bei rauskommt dennoch ist
diese art von decken in unserem alltag
glaube ich sehr sehr wichtig sehr
präsent wir schließen von einzelnen
fällen auf aufs ganze oder von der
vergangenheit auf die zukunft und das
glaube ich wir kämen gar nicht über die
runden wenn wir nicht erhalten so
induktiv schließen würde das team ist
ganz bestimmt
das ist ganz bestimmt zuerst will ich
nicht bestreiten ich würde gleich nur
ganz klein korrigieren es ist nichts
also der induktive schluss ist nicht gut
charakterisiert dadurch dass man sagt
dass das anschluss ist vom einzelnen
aufs allgemeine denn wir haben ja jetzt
zum beispiel also bei dieser
veranschaulicht und ging es uns auch
darum ist jetzt der nächste band auch
ein weißer oder ist es dieses ein
schwarzer es kann durchaus anschluss
seiner form von einzelnen auf das mac
system eingebaut und dann gibt es
natürlich auch induktion das muss man
vielleicht auch dazu sagen wenn man
natürlich spricht man auch von
induktiven beweisen dass ist dann noch
mal etwas anderes wird auch häufig ein
bisschen zusammen vermischt was
induktion ist möchte mit ihnen jetzt
noch ein bisschen über den alltag reden
um es da schleichen sich ja auch
logische fehler ab und zu vielleicht
können sie mal so müssen erläutert was
die gängige fehler sind die uns
unterlaufen wenn wir mit anderen
diskutieren als logischer sicht also man
spricht dann das ist dann nicht mehr
ganz logisch im engsten sehen dass im
formalen sind sondern man spricht dann
oft auch von kritikern oder so also wenn
man soll ich denke ich denke wenn man
solche dinge untersucht und dabei geht
es natürlich schon auch eben um ganz
alltägliche argumente die hier so
gebrauchen und da findet man gewisse
strukturen die dann möglicherweise auch
gewisse schwächen haben also mal ein
beispiel zu nennen
eine berühmte figur ist ist es in dieser
prominenten argumente dominieren
argumente hat man schnell wenn werden
prominent heißt das lateinische zielt
auf den menschen man sieht auf den
menschen also man wird nicht für die
wahrheit einer konklusion sondern man
kritisiert jemand das gegenteil
behauptet zum beispiel also
beispielsweise herr xy sagt man müsste
die steuern für reiche erhöhen
aber herr xy track nicht mal eine
krawatte also sollten wir die steuern
bereich nicht erhöhen also diese zweite
prämisse trägt nicht eine gerade die
detec überhaupt nichts dazu bei diese
kompression zu stützen sondern diese
person zu zu diskreditieren bzw auch das
eben was ich gesagt hat oder welche
meinung sie es würde man das jetzt ein
bisschen genauer analysieren dann würde
man wahrscheinlich sich überlegen müssen
wie gut auch weil ich im prinzip beruht
denn diese wies das argument ja auch
nicht das würde dann letztlich eine
stillschweigende prämisse sein dass
leute ohne krawatte keine zuverlässigen
informanten sind über über die
steuerpolitik und natürlich ein
absoluter schwachsinn aber es gibt ja
schon fälle wo man eher das sozusagen
gerechtfertigt zu sagen okay berühmtes
beispiel wenn jetzt der schüler zum
lehrer sagt irgendwie aber sie rauchen
und doch auch warum wollen sich mehr als
verbieten oder richtig das sind diese
sogenannten coco argument also du auch
ja die haben auch immer so schöne namen
diese die seriösen diese ganzen
argumente auch da ist ganz wichtig die
müssten nicht nicht diese dinge können
schon gewisse schwächen darstellen und
so typisches beispiel weil der arzt der
raucht und seine patienten sagt das
wirklich aufhören zu rauchen weil es
auch das ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen
dass das krebs verursacht und der
patient antwortet eben ja durchaus zur
selber natürlich können auch rauchen der
ärzte sehr gute informanten und experten
seien darüber was gut wäre zuerst zu
unterlassen also mir war es wichtig dass
man also oft sind diese diese man sagt
dann auch in formale logik ja sind diese
diese diese literatur ziehen vermag
logik die kranken franz ein bisschen
daran dass man als immer gleich als
fehlschlüsse bergleute das muss nicht
zwingend so sein zum beispiel sind
sogenannte autoritäts argumente
das ist ein bisschen wie der
zwillingsbruder von arminia weil hier
wird nicht hier wird in gewisser weise
werden auch personen ins spiel gebraucht
aber jetzt nicht um um die gegner zu
diskreditieren die das gegenteil
behaupten sondern weil man eben auf kurs
liegt auf autoritäten in bezug auf eine
bestimmte aussage also eine aussage ist
wahr weil dir und hier hat das gesagt
wenn ich zum beispiel sagen wir schon
platon meinte oder der bundesrat
empfiehlt kindern aus wären autoritäts
argument das werden sie genannt ist eine
autorität und versucht die eigene daten
dadurch zu begründen
genau oder für die baureihe eben diese
diese konklusion zu werden dadurch weil
seine autorität gesagt hat oder er das
und das gesagt und da hat immer jemand
ihn studiert oder das genauso figuren
die das können auch ganze gruppen seien
die autoritäten und streng logisch
gesehen ist das kein gültiger schluss
dass es folgt dann nicht daraus dass es
das richtige ist nur weil das bad
es ist leider so ja das nur weil jemand
etwas gesagt hat jetzt werde ich nicht
dass es auch zwingend war ist aber wie
gesagt dass wenn man dass man so ein
bisschen identifiziert hat und weiß okay
wir haben es hier mit einem mit einem
autoritäts argument zu tun
dann kann es schon sein dass man da
gewisse schwächen dann eben genau der
stelle entdeckt ja zum beispiel nur weil
eine person eine autorität ist auf einem
bestimmten gebiet heißt es ja nicht was
sie auch eine autorität ist dafür über
ein ganz für ganz andere zusammenhänge
also weil jemand ein guter sportler war
heißt ja nicht dass das das diese person
auch eine gute oder eine expertin ist
wenn es um drogen politik gibt und so
was viele fehler unterlaufen und sagen
wenn wenn wir mit solchen wenn daran
setzen dass die kommen in der logik aber
sie haben schon gesagt hypothetisches
denken also dass auch voraussetzung
beruht und wir haben da ein beispiel
vorbereitet wenn der ölpreis fällt dann
steigt der dollar hat das wäre jetzt
eine erste prämisse eine erste annahmen
und die zweite annahme wäre der ölpreis
fällt tatsächlich aus erfolgt logisch
daraus der dollar steigt jetzt
unabhängig davon ob die erste prämisse
oder die zweite wahl sind lassen wir
jetzt mal weg und jetzt bei diesen arten
von wenn dann setzen können uns leicht
fehler passieren können sie kurz
erläutern was ich sage vielleicht etwas
zum korrekten schluss zu
man nennt dann einen solchen modus
bohnen sehr also man hat ja einen
einsatz und behauptete zusätzlich aus
einem brennenden satz und behauptet im
einsatz und kann so zu sagen wenn dann
satz dann abspalten
das kann man schon ohne hebel ab diesen
ansatz zu verstehen dass ich weiß zum
beispiel nicht ob das war das wird
glaube ich gesagt das ist tatsächlich so
ist man weiß ich genau das habe so ist
deswegen auch das beispiel das spielt
auch keine rolle ob das stimmt aber wenn
dieser erste satz stimmt und der zweite
satz stimmt dann stimmt eben auch der
dritte was hat oft passiert bis zum
beispiel dass wir nicht sagt im zweiten
satz und ich stehen würde
der preis fällt sonderpreis fällt nicht
dass man dann darauf schließen dass der
dollar nicht stark und das folgt dann
wiederum nicht dass er ein formaler für
ihn schluss
und genauso werde ist ein fehlschluss
wenn statt des zweiten satzes der satz
da wäre also der den satz da wäre dann
steigt der dollar
also wenn der ölpreis fällt dann steigt
der dollar steigt also fällt der ölpreis
werde auch ein film schluss ok also das
heißt das ist wirklich eine bestimmte
herausforderung also es ist wirklich nur
dann logisch gültig wenn im zweiten satz
die zweite prämisse sozusagen den ersten
teil gehabt dieses wenn dann ist es wenn
dann satz man kann nicht eine zurück
schließen war kein land kann doch und es
gibt eine form das ist dann der modus
talents das ist wenn man noch so rennt
in den satz negiert also sehr dollar
steigt nicht
dann folgt daraus dass das nicht schon
genau wie wir machen nur ihre studenten
fehler wir ja und sie machen natürlich
werde ich mache auch ständig fehler ich
habe einst auch die vielleicht wichtig
ist weil sie haben gefragt weshalb ja so
viele fehler passieren
das hat auch damit zu tun dass wir
häufig gar nicht so genau unterscheiden
wenn wir reden frauen nur schnell reden
oder unbedacht zwischen wenn dann genau
dann wenn und nur wenn und das sind also
zb bei diesem beispiel dagestanden wäre
der ölpreis fällt genau dann wenn der
dollar steigt dann ist das was ich
vorhin anschluss beschrieben aber an
bedeutung ein gültiger schluss also sind
sind logische feinheiten ja aber das
kann schon es kann natürlich schon
darauf ankommen ob an übersetzungen
bändern geht oder um einen genau dann
wenn beispiel werden sie als logisch
denkender mensch nicht hin und wieder
verrückt wenn sie abends mit freunden
beim bier sitzen oder beim wein und über
gott und die welt reden und wenn es
irgendwelche politischen talkshows
schauen und auch diese fehler
entdecken mich mich mache ich eigentlich
hier die also die fehler machen mich gar
nicht so so wahnsinnig irgendwie kommt
er oder sein relativ selten auch
wirklich argumentiert wird also ich
würde sagen das ist sehr bedauerlich ja
das ist gar nicht so weit kommt dass man
tatsächlich jetzt mit logischen fehlern
zu tun oft werden hat einfach dinge
behauptet ja auch grundlos und auf
aufforderungen etwas zu begründen wird
auch dann auch nicht wirklich eine gute
begründung gebracht also das ist ich
finde ja dass ein bisschen ein
wissenschafter talkshows weiß ich haben
auch eine andere funktion denke ich
jetzt mal aus groß begründung kontexte
und und die präsentieren und den
persönlichen diskussion versuchen sie
dann den finger auf den punkt zulegen
und dabei zu bleiben und dem gegenüber
zu sagen das ist eine wertung versuchen
auch das zu begründen oder wie ich gehen
sie dann vor wenn jemand einfach abtun
erstellt also wenn wir nehmen einfach
nur behauptungen aufstellt dann versuche
ich natürlich schon ins gespräch zu
kommen ich sage es mal so ich glaube das
war auch immer eine bereitschaft des
gegenübers dass man das ist auch ein
bisschen risiko dass argumentieren ist
nicht einfach so das ist einfach so
passiert das passiert natürlich in
bestimmten kontexten hierzu eine
philosophie studium oder oder auch in
anderen studiengängen ist man isst man
sozusagen gelernt und das auch gezwungen
zu argumentieren
jetzt so im alltag das gebe ich gerne zu
da kann bei mir schon auch mal vorkommen
dass ich einfach sagt das ist so weil es
so wie es also
sie haben auch eine kleine tochter dann
könnte ja wir sind ja nicht auf die
philosophie gekommen stand da diese
faszination für die die logik für die
klare sprache am anfang oder waren heuer
die großen seen und lebensfragen die
situation also da setzt ein bisschen
eigentlich aber wissen wir und uns aber
also nie also das war hier zufällig
eigentlich das war in der
stadtbibliothek habe ich dann irgendwann
mal gedacht natürlich was ganz neues
lesen und ich will mich gar nicht
entscheiden welches buch ich dass ich
mich keine keine bewusste wahl treffen
und bin sozusagen blind mit
ausgestreckten wegen einfach auf ein
regal zugegangen und das war dann so ein
dickes möglich weiß ich was es war
dass jede sie mir doch zu viel und
daneben ein kleines rotes büchlein oder
wird das nämlich jetzt und das war das
war dann der tractatus von von von
wittenstein
und das war mein erstes buch das ich
irgendwo gelesen wir überhaupt nichts
von acatis logik wieder sowie kuss von
canon österreich und wieder so
faszinierend aber ich habe dann hat
philosophie studiert und und und und
aber auch vieles nicht verstanden das
hat sich eigentlich lange durchgezogen
aber ich kann mich gut erinnern an den
ersten logik großartig so dass erstmals
gefühl jetzt jetzt wird mir einiges
court und so dass ich glaube diese
faszination die hält die bis heute abend
also ich finde es auch für das
unterrichten einfach ein
das ist etwas vom schönsten täglich zu
unterrichten weil oft hat man es dann
auch in diesen listen diesmal h erlebnis
zu tun
jetzt ist mir klar und das ist schon mal
so das ist schon etwas feines und ich
finde auch wirklich eine solide logik
ausbildung
das ist jetzt nicht nur viele soviel
spezifisch überhaupt nicht
also dass es nun mit philosophie
nützlich wäre ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine gute sache ist ganz gewiss
das muss er dann nicht formal seien also
wir haben ja auch eine gewisse form
alice und wenn man logisch gemacht ich
kann auch ziemlich kompliziert werden
sondern einfach überhaupt diese diese
feinheiten dieses brauchs sprachliche
nuancen
das ein bisschen zu schauen ich glaube
dass das ist ein gutes auch mögen sie
uns auch zwei weitere tipps mit geben
wenn ich jetzt in einem gespräch bieten
und jemand behauptet das gegenteil das
kennt man ja aber irgendwie kann man die
anderen besuchen nicht widerlegen nicht
vom gegenteil überzeugen
gibt's da irgendwie tricks die sie uns
mit geben können
ich liebe das nächste mal in einer
diskussion nicht es wäre schön wenn es
so einfach wäre aber dass hier die
eleganteste form jemanden zu widerlegen
ist wahrscheinlich die reduktion
absurdum reduziert absolut die reduktion
absurd und das heißt eine was heißt dass
das heißt man man man zeigt dass eine
annahme zu einem widerspruch führt und
kann aufgrund dieses videos blogs dann
die annahme zurückweisen
und sie haben wir im vorgespräch gesagt
es gibt eine ganz berühmte reduktion
nämlich von galileo galilei den
berühmten physiker und philosophen der
es mit diesen beiden gegenständen
gemacht hätte ich gebe ihnen darüber
hinaus der hat der hat diese die annahme
um die es ging war die aristotelische
annahme dass die fallgeschwindigkeit
materielle körper proportional es zum
gewicht
das heißt schwieriger performance
schnell leichter körper fallen langsam
und luftwiderstand und so weiter kann
man beck denken und das war diana was
als schwere körper gelangt sein
und in diesen dialogen hatte hatte eine
figur die dreck ist das
gedankenexperiment vorträgen ich längst
letztlich eine reduktion sagt wendy wenn
dem wirklich so wäre dann müsste es
möglich sein dass man einen leichten
körper und einem schweren körper zu
einem körper vereint dann müsste aber
gemäss voraussetzungen was man die mit
einer schnur oder mit zehn jahren haben
wir genau zu einem körper vereint ja
dann müssten da müsste er gemäß
voraussetzung der leichtere körper den
schwere ein bisschen bremsen weil sie
hatte eine
andere oder eine langsamere
geschwindigkeit und der schwierigkeit es
hat das war die andere
also müssen sagen ein bisschen langsamer
fahren langsamer als der allein
gleichzeitig aber mit der genau gleichen
annahme müsste dieser verein tick
schneller fallen aus dieser allein weil
es zusammen ein bisschen schwerer ist
aus dieser lang aber ein körper kann
nicht zugleich langsamer und schneller
fallen
als dieser körper leyen das ist ein -
und das hat er ohne experimente zeigen
können sondern einfach bloß durch bloßes
logisches denken die sprossen und
logisches denken etwas über die welt ins
haus gewohnt nämlich die folgesätze und
jemanden widerlegt der die logik
sozusagen erfunden hat nämlich auch
wieso das ja das ist es auch sehr sehr
beeindruckend
aristoteles hat also zumindest hinter
menschen philosoph ich einfach gerade
mal so die erste logik so hingelegt ja
diese logistik also wir hatten hier ein
beispiel eingeblendet das geht einfach
etwas zurück solche schlüsse sind china
wies dies zurück also nicht nur diese
sondern hat seine ganze system von
diesen drei sätzen neben soziologischen
sind so ist es immer so drei sätze von
urteilen und aus zwei solchen urteilen
die somit alle keine einige folgt dann
ein drittes urteil mit öffentlichkeit
das ist die und wenn man sozusagen die
geschichte der logik sich am besten
vergegenwärtigt und sieht man es gibt
ganz viele stationen aber zwei sind ganz
ganz wichtig nämlich aristoteles
ziemlich am anfang und dann ein
deutscher mathematiker logik und
philosoph gottlob frege so ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts der das noch
mal ein bisschen durcheinander
gewirbelten was ich eigentlich sagen
also die geschichte die logik ist ist
sie hat viele viele kapitel aber das
sind jetzt sicher zwei ganz wichtige
kapitel also die die mit aristoteles
und mit konstrukt regen gott doch
wirklich sozusagen der begründer der
modernen logik und auch den
mathematischen logik
alle sind ein bisschen speziell auch wir
dazu gekommen ist er wollte eigentlich
etwas beweisen und hat gemerkt dass er
dafür gar nicht eine richtige sprache
hat die solche beweise zu führen was
beweisen wollte dass man etwas logisches
muss also die idee war dass arithmetisch
gesetze wie zum beispiel das zoomen
natürlicher zahlen immer größer ist als
hierzulande
da sind doch gesetze die irgendwie nicht
wie geometrische seit gesetzt sondern
sind irgendwie biologische gesetz es
muss doch möglich sein solche gesetze
übernatürliche zahlen auf logische
gesetze zurückzuführen also die
mathematik ganz einfach gesagt irgendwie
aber flog zurückzufahren so genau so wie
es ist und und na ja und er gemerkt dass
er eigentlich keine keine sprache als
solche beweise zu führen und das hat
eben dazu geführt dass ein begriff
schrift in seinem vertrag eine logik
verfasst und die war schon auch ein ein
meilenstein für dich sondern darum viel
weiter weiter auch weil beigetragen
zeitgenossen später diese die logik zu
formalisieren und weiter zu
systematisieren
aber was schon also um vielleicht noch
einmal zurück zur ist so etwas schon
möglich ist dass das dass das wirklich
gelang eigentlich einfach genug die
aristoteles da hingelegt hat einfach die
logik fahrer sind schon veränderungen
vorgenommen worden aber mehr oder
weniger was schon dass er als welt an
dem man sich an dem man sich orientiert
hat und es gibt auch heute leute die
sagen dass diese logik eigentlich unsere
der logik unserer alltagssprache ihren
wohn er kommt und dennoch so die sie
diese moderne logik die ausgehend von
pflegern entwickelt wurde
die mit logischen zeichen
die hat dabei geholfen dass man
bestimmte philosophische probleme auch
dann einfach lösen konnte indem man hat
natürliche setzte plötzlich logisch
analysiert hat versetzung dass also das
könnte man auch vielleicht an einem
beispiel dann da nun veranschaulichen
aber es gibt gewisse philosophische
probleme die sich tatsächlich durch mit
den mitteln der modernen logik dann
gelöst weil sich nicht aber sicher
besser in den griff
die hat unsere besser in den griff mögen
sie jetzt mal zeigen wie das wie das
ungefähr aussieht so eine logische
formalisierung haben hier stift und
papier
das war über also gut das wäre jetzt
vielleicht nehmen sie ein problem und
versuche oder einsam aber im moment ist
also nur zu einer form zu sehen ja das
problem
ein paar windows raus das war auch
jemand direkt ähnlich wie kontaktpflege
haben diesem projekt gearbeitet hat die
die thematik insbesondere die arithmetik
auf logische regeln zurückzuführen und
ein problem das nicht für dieses projekt
aber ein problem ein philosophisches
problem ist dass diese so genannten
negativen existenz setzte was wäre da
ein beispiel ein beispiel bei der
goldenberg existierte nicht das
geflügelte pferd existiert nicht also
setzte die von etwas sagen dass es nicht
existiert und das problem für rassen und
das scheitere auch später in seiner
autobiografie dass das sind das wirklich
lang also virgin kassel der britische
philosoph hatte genau so wie es der der
hat der hat er sagt auch dass er auch
wirklich jahrelang eigentlich war das
einfach ein problem denn diese setzen
den griff und vielleicht um es zu
verstehen ja was überhaupt das problem
ist ja eine weise das zu verstehen ist
so dass wir mit sagte goldene buch
existiert nicht dann sollte er diese
ganzen satz irgendwie bedeutsamen seiner
bedeutung auf
das heißt die teile die sie gegensatz
vorkommen sollten sich auf etwas
beziehen also in einer gewissen weise
müsste man sich auf diesen goldenberg
beziehen können von dem mann spricht und
von ihnen dann sagen dass eigentlich
existiert also das ist das problem also
wenn man etwas sagt dass es nicht
existiert muss man ja zuerst auf das
team bezug nehmen und dann von ihm sagen
dass es unser weg sein kann muss es
irgendwie irgendwo geben damit man von
ihm sagen kann dass das dann muss es
existieren wir existieren oder sub
sistieren also und dann tut man sich das
an schweren ich würde mich da kommt auch
komische philosophie oder kam dabei
komisch oder mac betrieben das in der
boom kommen oder vielleicht licht die
man nicht unbedingt vertreten
also was durchaus ein realist und die
lösung war das nennt man heute die
kennzeichnung als descriptions und das
war so für russland befreiungsschlag 19
58 ausgestoßen sagte gemerkt dass
ausdrücke die so bestimmte kennzeichnung
enthalten sowie die goldene berg dass
die implizit ganz komplexe aussagen
bereit sind und ich sage das jetzt
einfach mal wasser beschreibung die nur
genau auf ein objekt in erinnerung
riefen thema das in biologischen sprache
dann sowie ross auf geschrieben hatten
sieht das etwa so aus sagt uns ein
verkehrtes ge für es gibt jetzt kommt
eine variable es ein bisschen klein
vielleicht wie die kamera gemacht dass
kein knochen
es wird eben eine lange forderung
deswegen es gibt einiges ja sagen wir
uns mit dem goldenen berg
was heißt dieses xsp ist ein berg ist
ein berg und das ist ein zeichen für und
für alle hüppes i lon die ebenfalls
werke sind gilt dass diese y identisch
sind mit diesem mix
wir sind ja nicht so weit dass er genau
einem solchen berg haben und von diesem
sagen wir er sei gold also einmal ganz
genau weiß ob man hier noch weiter
glauben aber der wesentliche punkt ist
dass man jetzt von dieser ganzen
komplexen ausgesagt
sie sei falsch das ist die negation das
ist das zeichen wir also was gleich
nicht für alle aus der eigenen zeichen
auch für die existenz dieses umgekehrt
de zum beispiel das ist das und gibt es
zeichen und und wir haben wir das alle
und hier haben wir das was wir kennen
vielleicht ist verrückt wir haben einen
einfachen satz der wellenberg existiere
nicht und logisch analysiert sieht
dieser satz eigentlich so aus diese
relativ kompletter genau so hat man
jetzt dieses problem nicht mehr dass man
von etwas aussagen es existiert nicht
aber trotzdem muss ist das irgendwie
geben sondern in gewisser weise hat man
das problem so nicht also nicht in der
weise wie sich russell sich mit dem
problem zuerst konfrontiert gesehen hat
nämlich dass man von etwas sagen muss
das ist nicht existiert sondern man sagt
einfach es ist nicht so dass es ein
irgendetwas geht nix ja dass diese und
diese bedingungen erfüllt
es ist lustig weil unsere alltagssprache
ist ja eigentlich nicht wirklich logisch
so da gibt es viele ungenauigkeiten
wahrheiten mehrdeutigkeiten usw
und diese viele philosophen haben ja so
eine vision gehabt einer einer logischen
sprache die irgendwie klar ist aus
unserer alltagssprache und wollten
dadurch auch viele philosophische
probleme lösen brauchen wir das brauchen
wir so eine ideale logische sprache um
die welt überhaupt adäquat beschreiben
zu können
nein das glaube ich nicht dass und das
braucht ich glaube dass die logische
sprache jetzt auch so ein vormund
systeme wir das jetzt gesehen haben das
kann vielleicht helfen so gewisse dinge
klar zu kriegen aber um die welt zu
bescheiden brauchen wir letztlich ein
versprachen der also natürliche sprachen
und und und mit in diesen sprachen
äußern will und schreiben wir setzen auf
und und und beschreiben so damit die
welt wir denken das ist
ich denke dass so ein dass so eine eine
beschäftigung so eine sehr präzise
beschäftigung mit es braucht natürlich
schon auf gewisse feinheiten aufmerksam
machen kann
das ist sicher eine gute voraussetzung
wenn man die welt möglichst genau
gestalten will aber ein problem der
natürlichen sprache ist dass viele
ausdrücke nicht genau definiert sind
sage ich jetzt mal ausdrücken wie was
ist ein spiel oder was ist was bedeutet
wissen oder was ist würde ja viele
begriffe die in der philosophie eine
rolle spielen die einfach nicht scharf
definiert sie und da ich ja das ist
damit gut was macht man damit
man muss wahrscheinlich begriffe
erklären also ich habe eben ein bisschen
mehr mit dem begriff definiert weil das
klingt dann sonst könnte man als wäre
man gegen diesem zustand dass man
einfach sozial und grund die begriffe
definiert denn für die definition selber
braucht man ja schon wieder neue
zumindest wird ja also wir sind gar
nicht in dieser position eigentlich dass
wir eigentlich einfach klären können
also von tassen die begriffe es gibt
schon so automatische systeme die das
versuchen aber das unternehmen von
morgen
aber natürlich ist ein 1 1
wahrscheinlich ein wesentlicher zukunft
des sprachlichen verhaltens auch dass
man ihm erklärt ja also das man auch den
begriff klärt oder im gespräch findet
okay dass das sind wir uns da haben wir
uns da haben uns vielleicht
missverstanden oder wir haben noch gar
nicht klar die gleiche vorstellung und
erfolgen jetzt können solche und
feinheiten auch in schlüssen übrigens
ausgebeutet werden also absichtlich weiß
nicht ob ich das noch eher weniger
genial das ist so ein
ich habe das ganze letzte woche mit mit
mit den studierenden studierenden
gesprochen also übungsaufgabe das ist so
genannte emmental the paradox es geht so
was man sagt je mehr krise desto mehr
löcher
je mehr löcher ist er weniger kaiser
also je mehr krise desto weniger kaiser
sehr schön ist sie vielleicht noch mal
sagen aber ich sage noch einmal je mehr
käse desto mehr löcher je mehr löcher
desto weniger käse also je mehr krise
desto weniger käse was hier passiert ist
ist er unterhielt eben die logische
analyse vielleicht wie wir das eine so
genannte evokation das heißt man
verwendet einen ausdruck nicht in genau
der gleichen bedeutung und das passiert
hier zum beispiel mit dem ausdruck käse
weil in der ersten prämisse je mehr
krise desto mehr leute als man zum
beispiel so etwas wie ein stück käse ist
er mir solche hinziehen ist halt genau
bei der zweiten premiere
je länger desto weniger käse
da spricht man von der kesse menge was
ich mir in einem stück käse je mehr
löcher da drin sind desto weniger käse
menge relativ sozusagen zu den haltern
ok und deswegen kommt das schreien eines
gerichtlichen schluss also formal wäre
der schluss glücklich aber wenn man das
so sagen ausbuchstabiert diese diese
unschärfe diesen gesprächen herz beim
beim wort käse merkt man da wird er wird
überhaupt keinen keinen kein gültiges
muss also wird man zwei verschiedene
käse begriffe also dieses paradox kaum
lösen indem man genau hinschaut ob
wirklich die begriffe die genau gleich
aussehen nämlich ein käse und käse ob
die wirklich die gleiche bedeutung haben
in jedem einst und jetzt möchte ich noch
mal ein schritt zurück gehen und sie
haben ja gesagt die logik ist sind die
lehre des gültigen argumentieren dass
schließen und so das spielt für
begründung eine ganz wichtige rolle
jetzt ist es ja so wenn ich eine
behauptung begründen möchte muss sich
dazu auf andere behauptungen bezug
nehmen wir haben das gesehen beim
beispiel mit den philosophen die sterbe
ich sind dann kann ich sagen das sind
sie weil alle menschen sterblich sind
und alle philosophen menschen sind
aber diese behauptung auf die ich mich
stütze die muss sich ja wiederum
beweisen das heißt da müsste ich nochmal
andere behauptungen aufstellen und so
weiter das geht doch in uns ins
unendliche weiter deswegen die frage ist
dieses projekt oder die idee dass man
einen satz wirklich begründen kann
überhaupt irgendwie angemessen können
wir das überhaupt
ich sehe diese bedrohung nicht ganz so
dramatisch ganz ehrlich gesagt weil ich
habe eine sache die man vielleicht hier
auch sagen könnte dass eine begründung
oder wie es genau haben diese prämissen
konfusion in gewisser weise auch
relative begriffe sind also die
prämissen sind einfach prämissen für
sich sondern es im prämissen in einem
argument oder in einem begründung
versuch für eine bestimmte konfession
und genau so ist die conclusio nicht
einfach eine komplexe kommission kann
zum beispiel auch wiederum eine prämisse
eines anderen schluss sogar eines
anderen argument aber das ganze hängt
doch das ist der luft wenn ich ihr ja
nie weiß ob die prämissen war sind ja
okay gibt in gewisser weise ist das
sogar ein bisschen egal wenn sie jetzt
so etwas haben wollen wir eine lex
begründung jetzt an haben sie natürlich
ist es dieses münchhausen oder dieses
thema ja dass man endlich wir irgendwo
will ich diese kette im jahr
ja also fast jedes satz den man als
begründung angeführt ist wiederum seine
begründung bedürftig oder man baut einen
cent sagt er gut irgendwann dreht sich
das ding im kreis und dann hat man weiß
nicht ob oder wie zu fliegen dann
typischerweise sagt man muss man
automatisch festsetzen ja hier gilt
irgendein satz er lässt sich nicht
weiter begründet
ich bin nicht einmal bei diesem
dogmatischen dass das so so schlimm
das wäre durchaus ein ausweg also wenn
man jetzt diese begründung des regresses
besonders bedrohlich findet aber es doch
eher nicht das heißt wir begründen und
letztlich stützt sich das ganze auf ein
unbegründetes fundament
das würde ich so nicht sagen nein weil
weil also man muss also ich glaube wenn
das jemand behauptet würde ich würde ich
auch ein bisschen würde wahrscheinlich
dazu neigen diese person aufzufordern
ein bisschen zurück zu gehen das einfach
anbei ein paar schritte zurück gemacht
hinter begründung
und ich hab dann ändert dann auch ob man
sieht man stellt sich das immer so vor
oder das ist dann seine kette von dini
abbricht
aber wahrscheinlich kommt man dann schon
auch zu gewissen setzen die man wirklich
schwer findet ja gar nicht mehr wirklich
versteht wenn danach gefragt wird zum
beispiel was wäre denn ein grund dafür
zu denken dass dieses skeptische
philosophie die skeptiker in der
tradition haben natürlich ganz vieles
bezweifelt selbst dass wir wissen können
sie ein tisch ist oder dass das eine
hand ist wird ein letztlich könnte alles
ein traum sein und es ist logisch
möglich dass es so ist warum kommen mir
die dinge auch real vororts mehr was
macht man dagegen ja da muss man lange
nachdenken
also ich habe jetzt keine widerlegung
sodass skeptisch aber das ist schon das
ist eine sehr ernstzunehmende es ist ein
ernstzunehmendes problem denke ich auch
zumindest ja und ich glaube auch dass
das ist wirklich hilft aber das
philosophische denken schult wenn man
sich mit dem problem ernsthaft
auseinandersetzt
ich glaube aber nicht dass das problem
so gut gestellt die seinen sich einfach
fragte gut da können wir denn überhaupt
etwas wissen
und weil wir hier vielleicht für alles
was wir an führten würden die um etwas
behaupten würden dass man selber wieder
bezweifeln kann ja eine schlechte
skeptiker der verstrickt sich auch die
vielleicht etwas das so etwas wie ein
widerspruch ist aber wenn wir nämlich
eine behauptung aufstellt und sagte gut
alles ist bezahlbar so gut woher weiß
dann gut aus was wäre das also kein
argument ja aber wenn er sagt man kann
nichts wissen
oder man kann nichts wissen weil weiter
zu - das alles oder oder auch wenn er
sagt es gibt keine stichhaltigen
argumente denn jedes argument beruht
letztlich wiederum nur auf meinungen und
die sind sowieso anzweifeln bauen dann
können wir das verrät aufgehört ein
begründung versuchen könnte man
natürlich schon sich die frage glauben
aber gut gestützt und jetzt geht mit
diesem mit diesem stück rede dass du uns
dort vorgetragen
aber vielleicht können wir festhalten
dass auch in unserer gegenwärtigen zeit
es immer schwieriger zu werden scheint
zwischen wahren und falschen setzen zu
unterscheiden also wenn die uns im
internet um treiben da kursieren da alle
möglichen meinungen zu allen möglichen
themen und es von verschwörungstheorien
fair news falschmeldungen die die runde
machen und so weiter und im nachgang zu
der waffen und ramp sprach man sogar von
alternativen fakten oder von post
faktischen zeitalter das heißt irgendwie
dass die fakten gar keine rolle mehr
spielen dass es vielleicht so etwas wie
absolute wahrheit gar nicht gibt sondern
dass die immer konstruiert ist von uns
was sagen sie dass philosoph dazu diese
art von relativismus oder skepsis
berichtet es ganz schrecklich das war
absolut dabei sogar so dass ich genau
dem semester wie diese wahlkampf 1 1 ein
seminar und ich glaube zu tatsachen ja
unwissen damals natürlich also etwas was
dann noch vor aufteilt effekt
ich finde die ganze debatte verschleiert
auch ein bisschen was eigentlich
interessant sein könnte vom begriff der
tatsache oder anteil
ich denke schon zum beispiel etwas was
interessant ist oder ich würde mich
behauptet das jetzt mal so dass
tatsachen wesentlich sprachlich
individuen dividiert werden
sie können nicht sehr gut auf tatsachen
zeigen wenn ich jetzt hier so zeige dann
wissen sie nicht zeige ich jetzt auf die
tatsache dass sie ein stein steht dass
hier die feder gewissen teil ist und
kann es tauchen nicht zeigen
aber man kann sich natürlich in sätzen
beschreiben das heißt es gibt es ein
wesen also man kann auf gegenstände
zeigen
auf diesen stein aber nicht auf die
tatsache dass er da auf dem tisch liegt
ist man kann natürlich schon in diese
richtung zeigen des steins aber man kann
mit den zeigen nicht eine tatsache
individuen sondern die integrierung der
tatsache diese wesentlich würde ich
sagen
abhängig von den satz und da ich habe da
steckt so ein denkfehler denn da könnte
man denken ja gut dann ist also die
existenz der tat auch abhängig von
besprochen sondern kommt eine abi theres
moment rein das erfahrungsfeld was
stimmt ist dass die beschreibung der tat
auch wesentlich sprachlich ist und die
individualisierung der tatsache aber die
tatsache existiert auch unabhängig davon
dass sie beschrieben wird möglich ist
dass beiden tatsachen so dass die
unabhängig davon dass wir also solche
tatsachen also können wir wird man das
wer wird da beginnt ein blutfleck
genannt also steine und jährige die
höher sind als andere berge und dann
gibt es auch diese unterscheidungen
daneben zu sozial konstruierten
tatsachen also zum beispiel john searle
spricht immer von cocktailpartys geld
und so weit ist alles dinge oder dass
dieses stück papier eine banknote ist
mit diesem diesem wert das ist eine
sozial konstruierte tatsache
deswegen weil wir das alle glauben und
als solches akzeptieren dass in 15
franken
genau jetzt genau und für diese also was
für diese tatsachen wesentlich ist eben
der sprecher also man muss eigentlich
einen es muss eine übereinkunft sein
wenn man sagt eben hiermit zum beispiel
ist die sitzung eröffnet damit schafft
man eine tatsache nämlich meine
öffentliche sitzung ist aber wesentlich
abhängig von diesem sprecher des des
eröffnungs und ebenso auch für andere
soziale tatsachen gibt schon
unterschiede sozusagen mit
unterschiedlichen tatsachen
also ich laden wirklich es gibt irgendwo
da draußen tatsachen die sind ganz
unabhängig davon von uns wie wir darüber
reden und denken und war wahrheit wäre
dann so etwas wie eine übereinstimmung
mit diesen tatsachen oder wie wie
verstehen sie in der nacht wahrheit also
ich liebe es natürlich auch ganze
palette an theorien zur wahrheit ist ist
groß ich habe es eine korrespondenz
typischerweise sagen ja sowie gewachsen
dem wir hatten sie vertreten ein einsatz
ist war genau dann wenn ihr mit den
tatsachen überein stimmt für andere ist
ist wahrheit hier ist eine frage der
kohärenz ja also freuen wenn sich eine
position call and einfügt in ein ganzes
system von von proposition untersetzt
ist habe ich opposition gesagt das ist
ein philosoph in schalke gut setzte
nehmen also wie gut eine meinung zu
anderen meinung passt einfügt in das was
ich schon um der wahrheit die vielleicht
dann gibt es auch so kritische theorie
ich glaube ich glaube auch nicht also
ich weiß dass ich wenn ihr wenn ihr beim
tatsache und bewegungs am besten ein
bisschen bleiben wollen
je nach theorie die man so wahrheit hat
verändert sich möglicherweise auch die
tatsachen begriff habe ich glaube was
ein fehler wäre zu denken ja gut
tatsachen sind so etwas wie dinge da
draußen also
jetzt ein bisschen dargestellt haben der
krieg ist also dass diese dinge da
draußen sind ich glaube der fehler auf
denen ich aufmerksam machen wollte ist
hier dass man manchmal von der
schwierigkeit die tatsachen zu
beschreiben die tatsachen genau zu
beschreiben die tatsachen zu erkennen
daraus schließt dass es nicht möglich
ist wurde dass sie gar nicht existieren
und ich glaube das ist ein ist ein
fehler den wir nicht machen sollten
diese gesetze der logik über die wir
gesprochen haben sind die eigentlich
eher in unserem kopf drin und der art
wie wir über die welt denken oder sind
dass gesetze der welt die wir entdecken
der logik also wenn sie in unserem kopf
werden werden sie auch in der welt da
wäre in der welt sind also so gesehen
war das gar nicht so ein gegensatz ich
vermute sie malen sind es jetzt so etwas
wie denkt gesetze oder sind geht es noch
weiter sind es auch gesetze die
sozusagen die struktur der welt
festlegen
ich glaube dass er sich jetzt so etwas
wie also hier das erste aber jetzt nicht
in dem sinn dass sie beschreiben wie wir
denken sondern hier beschreiben wir
denken sollte also wissen was normatives
und ich meine also das habe ich
natürlich von von pflege und natürlich
meine beschäftigung mit feger die der
bescheid ist ungefähr so wie gesagt dass
eine richtschnur für das denken logische
gesetze die beschreiben wie man denken
soll
und ich finde das schön finde ich dass
deutschland wie hier sagt er sagt nicht
was man denken sondern wie man denken
soll
also eben entsprechend den gesetzen
gesetzen der logik ja was man denkt das
ist dann sozusagen das ist das also dass
ich sozusagen seine eine nicht
dogmatisch erhalten dazu werden
dann nehmen wir noch denken was man will
aber da sind ja wir haben hier ja
gesehen dass die wahrheit dieser
einzelnen sätze keine rolle spielt dafür
auf der schlussnotierung es aber nicht
was würden sie sagen hilft die logik er
neue wahrheiten zu finden wie wir das
bei galileo und dem steinigen weg
gesehen haben oder hilft sie ihr dabei
falsche aussagen zu vermeiden
natürlich eine ganze wahnsinn hilft sie
sowieso wahrheiten zu binden sie einfach
unsere werte unsere arbeit suche ist
sowieso an leitet also gekommen ja gar
nicht darum herum sozusagen logisch zu
denken ist die logik für mich da ist ein
bisschen schwer ehrlich gesagt ich denke
dass sie das dass das ist gut
diese gesetze die sie gesetzt ein
bisschen zu kennen und damit zu
operieren
das schult auch sein wissen das logische
denken und passt daher vielleicht
einfach einen vorteil sein
der beschäftigung mit logik sondern auch
ein bisschen eine reflexion auf das
eigene band genau
und wir haben jetzt ja in dieser stunde
schon einige logische schlüsse und
fehlschlüsse kennengelernt und falls sie
zu hause interesse haben noch mehr
nachzulesen
mehr vier schüsse und mehr logische
argumentation kann ich ihnen diese
beiden bücher empfehlen das gelbe ist
von dem schweizer wieder so von jonas
pfister werkzeuge des philosophierens
und das andere von dem us amerikanischen
philosophen john rosenberg
philosophieren ein handbuch für anfänger
zum schluss vielleicht auch die frage
was ist für sie als philosoph eigentlich
das
schwierigste problem das schwierigste
philosophische problem nachdem sie sich
schon mal auseinander gesetzt haben das
schwierigste philosophische problem
schreibt dass ich das das kenne ich noch
nicht weil ich alle ziemlich schwierig
finde wenn man sich genau damit
beschäftigt also wenn es ein
schwierigstes gebe dann werde es so dass
alle anderen weniger schwierig werden
aus dienst- und das also so wie wir das
jetzt mit dem russell beispiel
aufgezeichnet haben ja und dass das ist
mir einfach noch selten passiert dass
ich irgendwie doch das so jetzt habe ich
das problem gelöst so wie sicher so dass
es mit genauer beschäftigung dann
eigentlich auch immer glauben aktiv ist
ein bisschen in den griff vielleicht
oder man kennt man kann es ein bisschen
darauf bewegen oder gänzlich gewisse
muss aber lösen das passiert hat schon
sehr selten man denkt dann vielleicht ja
gut da muss man sich weiter denkt weil
das ist da passiert nichts sagt
einfädeln oder so ich habe kein könig
ein schwieriges problem entstehe ihn zum
zum schluss noch mal ein paradox und bin
gespannt ob sie das lösen können sie
haben schon das emmentaler paradoxen es
gibt noch das sogenannte barbier paradox
angenommen sie werden jemand der andere
leute rasiert ein barbier und sie würden
alle menschen rasieren die sich nicht
selber rasieren und jetzt die frage was
machen sie mit ihrem eigenen bad
da sehen sie sich selbst oder nicht
haben sich auf diese lösung und von
draußen also man muss jetzt um es genau
zu sagen also diese papierbasiert alle
und nur die also genau die die sich
nicht zu produzieren
die produktion läuft darauf hinaus dass
sein paket kann es nicht geben also die
frage die sich stellt ist also was würde
ich tun wenn ich jemand wäre den es
nicht geben kann würde ich mich rasiert
ehrlich gesagt mir nicht wenn ich etwas
wäre dass es nicht geben kann ich weiß
nicht ob rasieren mein größtes problem
geht das nachher wissen das heißt wenn
der sich selbst rasieren würde dann
dürfte er das nicht tun weil er rasiert
nur diejenigen die sich nicht selbst
hasst und wenn er sich nicht rasiert
dann müsste er sich gleich anfangen zu
rasieren war rasiert die sich nicht und
wenn wir das selber werden wir dort
passieren wir geben ihnen zu hause
dieses rätsel mit und hoffen sie können
das lösen ihnen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
ich danke für das gespräch ja danke fürs
mitdenken nächste woche spricht meine
kollegin barbara bleisch mit zwei der
renommiertesten deutschsprachigen
intellektuellen über die welt nach
gronau zu gast sind die publizistin
carolin emcke und der sozialpsychologe
harald welzer sollten sie auf keinen
fall verpassen und jetzt gleich widmet
sich die sternstunde musik einer der
schillerndsten figuren der
musikgeschichte nämlich den komponisten
und mörder carlo jesse alten bleiben sie
also dran und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]